We, as visual artists, remain committed to our belief, remain
committed to the responsibility of lightening the image and highlighting the
repeated crimes of the occupation against our
safe and sound children. We express through our
artistic works and embody through Amman’s art what our
children see of aggression, crimes and
killings committed by this occupation by
conveying a message as an artist to the world: Look at
Our children, these children who
fight one war after another, are children no less
important than the children of the world. Our children have the right and they have the
right to live in safety and they have the right to
live freely and in stability
[music]